[Hank:] ♫Any dolt with half a brain♫
[Hank:] ♫Can see that humankind has gone insane♫
[Hank:] ♫To the point that I don't know, if I'll upset that status quo, if I throw poison in the water main♫
[Hank:] ♫Listen close to everybody's heart and hear that breaking sound♫
[Hank:] ♫Hopes and dreams are shattering apart and crashing to the ground♫
[Hank:] ♫I cannot believe my eyes♫
[Hank:] ♫How the world's filled with filth and lies♫
[Hank:] ♫Cause it seems to me, the evil inside of me, is on the rise♫
[Katherine:] ♫Look around, we're living with the lost and found♫
[Katherine:] ♫Just when you've feel you've almost drowned, you find yourself on solid ground♫
[Katherine:] ♫And you believe there's good in everybody's heart, keep it safe and sound♫
[Katherine:] ♫With hope, you can do your part, to turn a life around♫
[Katherine:] ♫I cannot believe my eyes, is the world finally growing wise?♫
[Katherine:] ♫Cause it seems to me, some kind of harmony, is on the rise♫
[Hank:] ♫Any dolt with half a brain♫
[Katherine:] ♫Take it slow♫
[Hank:] ♫Can see the whole world howling in pain♫
[Katherine:] ♫And he looks at me and seems to know♫
[Hank:] ♫And the dark is everywhere and Penny doesn't seem to care, that soon the dark in me is all that will remain♫
[Katherine:] ♫The things that I'm afraid to show and suddenly I feel this glow♫
[Hank:] ♫Listen close to everybody's heart♫
[Katherine:] ♫And I believe there's good in everybody's heart♫
[Hank:] ♫And hear that breaking sound♫
[Katherine:] ♫Keep it safe and sound♫
[Hank:] ♫Hopes and dreams are shattering apart♫
[Katherine: ] ♫With hope, you can do your part♫
[Hank:] ♫And crashing to the ground♫
[Katherine:] ♫To turn a life around♫
[Hank & Katherine: ] ♫I cannot believe my eyes♫
[Hank:] ♫How the world's filled with filth and lies♫
[Katherine:] ♫How the world's finally growing wise♫
[Hank:] ♫Cause it seems to me♫
[Katherine:] ♫And it's plain to see♫
[Hank:] ♫Evil inside of me♫
[Katherine:] ♫Rapture inside of me♫
[Hank & Katherine: ]♫Is on the rise♫
[Hank:] We were gonna have the orange in it  but it didn't make it.
[Hank:] Cause we had to do it 27, possibly 28 times, before we got it,
[Hank:] and we thought the orange would've added another level of complexity.
[Katherine:] The orange is not easy to play.
[Hank:] ♫I cannot believe my eyes, how the world's filled with growing wise♫
[Hank:] Yeah, it's filled with growing lives, as well.
[Katherine:] And wolves and wives.
[Hank:] Darkness and evil girls.
[Katherine:] Of dolphin game
[Hank:] Thank you for doing that with me
[Katherine:] It was very frustrating.
[Hank:] It was!
[Katherine:] Love you though.
[Hank:] But, but it worked.
[Hank:] Time for outtakes!
[Katherine:] ♫Lost and found, cause when you feel you've almost drowned♫
[Katherine:] ♫I cannot believe my eyes♫
[Katherine:] Or my ears.
[Hank:] Sorry.
[Hank:] Jesus, you screw up one chord and she devours you.
[Katherine:] One chord.
[Hank:] ♫Shake that orange baby, shake that orange, shake-a it♫
[Hank:] It's a little too close to my face right now.